voudrais vous parler d'un dernier truc
maintenant une chose qui fait énormément
polémique depuis ce week-end alors on
devra avoir absolument votre avis c'est
la série emblématique les simpson tout
le monde tout le monde connaît les
simpson
ils ont décidé de se séparer d'un des
personnages qui était accusé de racisme
ce personnage c'est abou un indien
gérant d'une épicerie et père de famille
de huit enfants
vous avez un magnéto sur ce qu'est le
style à poux et rendez vous compte c'est
terminé c'est fou parce qu'on voit
partout à pont est sorti ce mois du
dessin animé
dites nous ce que vous en pensez et pas
seulement des deux via le web
alors mes frères mange à mener c'est
payant pour nous aider dans ces temps de
nécessite je vous en prie mais tu
n'étais pas de paille un seul enfant
sanomat le césium des vents la tête de
singe qui appelait le soleil pour une
mangue mûre
bon enfin je comprends pourquoi vous
dites ça s'il n'y avait que vous étiez
un super tireur au oui tous les gérants
des mini market doivent parquet les
sports de combat alors cette décision je
voudrais vraiment si vous êtes avec nous
restez que parce que je suis pas j'ai
vraiment envie vraiment d'avoir votre
avis parce que là c'est incroyable donc
le producteur des simpson a dit chan car
l'annoncé ce week-end il ne fera plus
partie des projets un épisode des
simpson cette décision fait suite un
documentaire sorti l'année dernière où
plusieurs personnalités d'origine
indienne expliqué le calvaire vécu par
rapport aux stéréotypes qu'il ya dans la
série ce documentaire est fait beaucoup
de bruit à l'époque où vous ont appris
un extrait et donc il ya des fans qui
sont très très énervé bien sûr sur
twitter j'ai envie d'avoir votre avis
aussi est votre avis aussi autour de la
table
ou alors voilà c'était ce documentaire
qui a fait beaucoup parler et depuis
donc ce personnage à poux est retiré des
simpson dites nous la vérité ce que vous
en pensez
c'est vrai que je sais que c'est dur
voilà de prendre parti là dessus après
on voit dans ce commentaire qui a des
gens qui ont vraiment souffert et voilà
qu'ils souffrent jour le jour mais là on
peut comprendre mais le producteur
lui-même a dit chan car il est il a dit
un truc moi que je trouve assez
intéressant il le fait à regret parce
qu'il se dit qu'il n'a pas le choix et
que si ça a blessé
eh bien il faut il faut le retirer mais
en même temps et dit ce n'est ce n'est
ni un pas en avant ni un pas en arrière
c'est tout simplement a pas de côté si
vous faites une série qui traite de
différentes cultures et que vous avez
trop peur de parler de ces cultures
vous êtes tout bonnement une série qui
est lâche et voilà ça veut dire que ce
soit au problème est que justement on
moi je trouvais que c'était leur moyen
aussi de dire on est tous ensemble et
justement nos différences on les célèbre
et on s'amuse avec aller très vite gille
c'était une caricature que c'est devenu
une caricature notamment dans les
doublages mais au même mois il a grandi
donc je suis caricature c'est raciste
aujourd'hui tout ce qui est raciste on
l'éliminé on est derrière eux c'est la
matière et ville animée donc les
personnages caricaturaux alors au maire
et un gros bond de l'admirer sont tous
ya eu deux épisodes où il y avait un
gars c'était hilarant c'est une folle
furieuse comme j'ai trois tonnes tout
est dans la caricature c'est ce qui fait
baisser au contraire c'est à dessein et
qui dénonce toutes les caricatures il ya
le gros raciste gros beauf le match si
t'as pas compris ça t'as rien compris en
arrière et jean-michel et on est tous la
caricature de quelqu'un dans certains
pays on se fout de nous ont soudain
fougue les français sont râleurs qui
sont joints radin et cetera
ainsi on se moque de de certaines
consulter de la gueule pendant 40 ans
des belges a pas un mec il n'y a pas un
pakistanais car galeo dix ans pour qu'on
se moque des belges
l'humour accès sous moi j'espérais voir
du racisme partout chez lui